the great labor leader once said
you can't play politics with people's
jobs with people's services or with
their homes
as a clear warning against the dangers
of rigid dogma and impossible promises
as you will ever see now you might
recognize it I certainly do
but it's not just in that great footage
of Neil
no
I see that attitude
the very same thing he was fighting
against in the behavior of the Tories
these past few weeks and now we see the
result the grotesque chaos of a Tory
prime minister handing out redundancy
notices to our own Chancellor
and Conference there are no historical
precedents for what they've done to our
economy
now Britain has faced Financial crises
before
but the prime ministers and chancellors
who wrestled with them all acted fast
when their policies ran against the
rocks of reality they took decisive
action
but this lot
they didn't just tank the British
economy
they also clung on
clung on as they made the pound sink
clung on us they took our pensions to
the brink of collapse clung on as they
pushed the mortgages and bills of the
British public through the roof
they did all of this
all the pain our country faces now is
down to them
and there's still one person Clinging On
the prime minister
no doubt we'll hear plenty of laughable
excuses in the coming days
after 12 years of stagnation
that's all her party has left
but even they know
she can't fix the mess that she's
created
and deep down
her MPS know something else
they no longer have a mandate from the
British people
no mandate for an outdated ideology
which says it's the rich and only the
rich who drive this country forward
no mandate for unfunded promises that
destroy our economic stability
no mandate for an economic policy that
says we can't see your struggles our
Dogma has drawn the curtains
it's a conference know this
whatever they say now
whatever they do
it boils down to one argument for them
it's party first country second and
that's unforgivable the change this
country needs
is a labor government
because whatever damage they do
we remain bold on reform on renewal on
National reconstruction
that's what the British people expect
from a labor government
and we will deliver it
it's what we did in 1945
went out of the rubble of the second
world war we built a land fit for Heroes
it's what we did in 1964 when we
harnessed the white heat of technology
to pay our way in a modern economy
in 1997 when we modernized a country
held back by crumbling public services
and outdated institutions it's up to us
to write the next chapter of Labor
history together
about how we built a fairer Greener more
Dynamic Britain by tackling the climate
emergency head-on
and used it to create the jobs the
industries the opportunities of the
future our new chapter of Labor history
across the world
countries are already gearing up to meet
this challenge
we can't afford to miss out
because some nation is going to lead the
world in offshore wind why not this one
Nation will win
some Nation will win the race for
electric vehicles why not us some Nation
will be the first to harness new
hydrogen power why not Britain
that's what our green Prosperity plan is
all about
its action on the cost of living crisis
now tomorrow and the day after
and it starts by backing working people
on Rising Energy prices
when the prime minister in the summer
was arguing against handouts remember
that
labor provided the clarity our nation
needed we said this winter not a penny
more on anyone's bills and we'd make
sure that the oil and gas companies pay
their fair share
thank you
but to end this National Emergency once
and for all we also need a long-term
plan
a plan that will deliver cheaper bills
for working people now and in the future
growth and jobs in every part of our
country
and real independence from tyrants like
Putin who weaponize fossil fuels and
threatened our security
that is the central mission of the next
Labor government we will turn Britain
into a green growth superpower
and driving us forward
will be a goal that puts us ahead of any
major economy in the world
a hundred percent clean Power by 2030.
a goal that means investment
in Wind solar nuclear hydrogen green
steel and carbon capture
training for plumbers electricians
Engineers software designers technicians
and builders
a national Sovereign wealth fund that
generates growth and private investment
insulation for 19 million homes
and Great British energy a publicly
owned company that takes advantage of
the opportunities in clean British power
and turns them into good secure high
paid British jobs
the argument for our plan
is very simple
clean energy is already cheaper than
fossil fuels
nine times cheaper
working people need more of it Britain
needs to own it and the jobs and growth
it creates must be shared with every
Community British power to the British
people
and that's why I've always said
we will fight the tourists on economic
growth
it's not just their record the worst
decade for growth in two centuries this
isn't a problem of the last three or
four weeks
the worst decade for growth in two
centuries
the Vicious Cycle of stagnation as the
now former Chancellor calls it quick
edit to the speech as we came up
yesterday on the train
but we have a clear and practical plan
to spread the opportunities of the
future to every community in Britain
that's why we struggle for growth
we lock too many communities out of the
wealth that we create
we create too many jobs that are low
paid and insecure and our Public
Services aren't strong enough to help
working people succeed
the Tory trickle-down fantasy has no
answer to this
working people won't be better off
if we make the rich richer
it's fantasy economics
if you leave this many people behind a
nation cannot grow fairly
so we will invest in clean hydrogen
power and create new opportunities here
in South Yorkshire
we will radically expand offshore wind
in Grimsby East Riding North Yorkshire
all the way up the coast
solar panels generating incomes for
farmers and Rural communities and home
insulation putting cash in working
people's pockets right across this
region